aux etats-unis en europe je me suis
invitée chez ces philanthropes
richissime d entretien exceptionnel avec
les nouveaux maîtres du monde avant leur
temps n'est pas de leur argent les gates
ont déjà lâché 36 milliards de dollars
mélinda épouse de bill est une féministe
planétaire
et si vous mettez les femmes au centre
tout se met à aller mieux et le pl se
développe chez xavier niel le premier
geek de france avoir trop d'argent et
vous avez des gens toujours plus riche
en annonces à posera problème
vous avez quand même besoin d'une
manière ou d'une autre de partager ou
warren buffet est le gourou de wall
street
troisième fortune mondiale à
sur les 65 milliards de dollars que je
possède 64 trois quarts ne me servent à
rien mais ils peuvent être utiles aux
autres ils peuvent acheter des vaccins
de l'éducation il peut faire beaucoup de
choses
en france ces milliardaires fascine mais
on s'en méfie sont ils sincères dans
leur démarche
ou bien est-ce seulement de la com en
tout cas les fondations philanthropiques
sont toujours plus nombreuses et leur
action se fait sentir partout dans le
monde d effet papillon que mon équipe
est elle est mesurée
jaguar n'a dit s'est envolé pour le
sénégal où les gates finances la
contraception pour tout ce déchet dans
la colère de certains imams
c'est pour aider les jeunes filles
sénégalaises et de faire dodo riches au
kenya hugo van hoof allait retourner en
classe là bas mark zuckerberg investi
dans des écoles pour les plus pauvres et
ils remplacent les profs par des
tablettes comme tout est écrit
je veux savoir ce qu'elle va dire enfin
nathalie crowe a fait du tourisme
médical dans les caraïbes
les américains viennent s'y faire opérer
dans un hôpital à prix cassés ouvert par
un richissime médecin indien l'inde qui
soigne l'amérique le sud qui vient au
secours du nord c'est le monde à
l'envers
la vraie fine entre office et offrir aux
gens des services à un prix accessible
à la fin de ce film le futur aura
commencé l'humanité aura quinze mille
habitants de plus les fondations auront
dépensé des dizaines de millions d'euros
plus et nous nous saurons s'il faut
vraiment dire merci à ces milliardaires
si généreux pas vraiment au rendez vous
à
quatre ans de prison
notre voyage commence aux états unis
dans la ville réputée la plus généreuse
au monde
seattle le plus grands philanthropes de
l'histoire est un enfant du pays
bill gates il s'inscrit dans une
tradition très américaine quand on a de
l'argent on donne c'est une obligation
morale est une manne financière pour
ceux qui reçoivent souvent les riches
remplace l'état
prenez le théâtre public de seattle pour
boucler son budget pas de subvention ni
des donateurs privés
lui c'est le patron du théâtre l'endroit
est top non ce soir il organise une
vente aux enchères pour vip
merci d'être venus merci on va lever
beaucoup d'argent ce soir voyez tout le
monde s'est mis sur son 31
on va passer du bon temps vous espérer
récolter combien ce soir l'objectif
c'est un demi million de dollars
il faudra enlever les frais mais bon
l'espoir ses 512 un demi million pour
les invités c'est l'occasion de montrer
publiquement qu'ils ont du coeur et
qu'ils font leurs devoirs
j
est-ce que je vous le dis je vais mettre
moins 5000 $
j'adore donner pour cette cause vous
savez combien vous allez donner ce que
ce soit
oh non je ne sais pas on verra bien ici
ce n'est pas comme en europe l'argent
public est loin d'être suffisant pour
faire vivre la culture
les donateurs sont là pour deux heures
seulement il faut vite faire chauffer la
machine à cash
vous êtes prêt à lâcher un bon paquet ce
soir à peine le temps de toucher à son
assiette
lot numéro un une escapade de trois
jours à santa fe
4000 6000 8000 juste là cette mise en
scène de la générosité ferait ricaner en
france pas aux états unis ici chacun
fait sa b1 en public trois
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
sont pendus pour 2700 $ c'est tout le
côté démonstratif dumont souaré levée de
fonds chacun livre sa pancarte et veut
participer
c'est comme une compétition oui il ya un
peu de ça c'est tout le monde à ma table
lève sa pancarte je vais être gêné de ne
pas lever la mienne c'est une incitation
forte c'est contagieux quelqu'un d'autre
parce que là vous avez droit à vos
propres applaudissements c'est comme ça
que ça fonctionne mais au final c'est
pour la bonne cause
ordu pour 12000 dollars aux deux fois
c'est l'heure des comptes il fallait
dépasser le demi-million $
pari gagné on vient de lever 570000
dollar
merci à vous tous
[Applaudissements]
voilà c'est ça seattle c'est comme ça
qu'on soutient ce qui ne tient à coeur
là je suis hyper content maintenant je
vais boire et danser toute la nuit
pourquoi seattle est elle si généreuse
d'abord parce qu'elle est riche
boeing starbucks et amazon sont nés ici
mais à seattle personne n'égale bill
gates retraite ou des affaires il s'est
lancé dans la philanthropie et là aussi
il est devenu le number one avec une
spécialité la santé il a déjà son musée
où il écrit sa légende
pas celle du geek celle de l'homme de
bien
elle vous souhaite la bienvenue au mercy
dans sa croisade
bill a embarqué sa femme melinda le
couple de super riches
s'il ya le monde à la recherche de la
bonne cause
[Musique]
vous êtes là pour votre nouveau site
internet vous irrite jusqu'où pour en
faire la pub c'est vraiment important
pour melinda et moi du coup je serai
prêt à faire n'importe quoi
démonstration avec ce clip tourné pour
le même taux que shaw les gates n'ont
pas peur de casser leur image
[Musique]
2ème communiqué enfin selon leurs
propres règles
il nous a fallu six mois pour accéder au
siège de leur fondation
les autorisations de tournage sont
rarissimes et millimétrée bill et
melinda ont vu grand ici les employés
sont payés pour donner 15 millions de
dollars chaque jour le double de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé oms
[Musique]
ben il s'est beaucoup investi dans les
vaccins mélinda elle s'est trouvé sa
propre cause celle des femmes perry et
l'une de ses adjointes pour l'afrique un
jour de 2011
mélinda nous a réunis et elle nous a
annoncé qu'elle avait décidé de faire du
planning familial
l'oeuvre de sa vie l'année suivante
notre budget a été multiplié par deux
mélinda c'est la pasionaria de la
contraception pour libérer les femmes
elle veut réduire les naissances et
infléchir la démographie mondiale à on
voit que vous avez déjà beaucoup de
bonnes idées
aujourd'hui mélinda pèse lourd c'est
l'une des femmes les plus puissantes au
monde
elle accorde des interviews au compte
gouttes
me voici en face à face première
question sur les effets papillon de
melinda gates une simple décision prise
par vos assiettes homme peut changer la
vie de millions d'êtres humains ce que
ça vous donne le vertige
seattle
on essaie de prendre des décisions
mûrement réfléchie en nous appuyant sur
des données des statistiques du monde
entier il et moi pensons que les règles
du business doivent s'appliquer et que
c'est ainsi qu'on fait la meilleure
investissement tous les jours quand je
passe la porte de la fondation j'essaye
de penser aux femmes et aux hommes que
j'ai rencontrées sur le terrain à ce
qu'ils m'ont demandé à leur vie qu'ils
veulent améliorer et j'essaie de
toujours garder ses histoires en tête
que je sois à seattle en train de
travailler ou que j'intervienne auprès
des gouvernements
au nom de ces hommes et de ces femmes
diriez-vous many dogs est une féministe
oui je dirais que je suis féministe
absolument pour moi le féminisme c'est
de responsabiliser les femmes parce que
si vous mettez les femmes au centre
tout se met à aller mieux et le pays se
développe la femme et le centre du foyer
c'est elle qui décide
qu'ils mangent et qu'est ce qu'on en
sait un peu d'argent dans les mains elle
en reverse 90% depuis que la fondation
exif devait rencontrer des milliers de
gens sur le terrain y at il une histoire
qui vous a plus marqué que toutes les
autres en 2012
j'étais dans un bidonville près de
nairobi et une femme qui s'appelait
marianne a tout résumé en une phrase
elle m'a dit je veux donner tout ce
qu'il faut à ma fille avant d'avoir un
autre enfant
et là j'ai compris que ces femmes
savaient ce qui est la contraception et
nous supplier d'y avoir accès elles
savent qu espacer les naissances leur
permet d'avoir des enfants en bonne
santé qui peuvent aller à l'école et
c'est comme ça qu'elles sortent leur
famille de la misère moins d'enfants
plus de richesses l'équation sont les
simples et voici l'armé secrète de
melinda
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jaguar analyse de la team papillons a
suivi la trace des sirènes de melinda
gates jusqu'au sénégal où le
contraceptif un effet secondaire il
donne de l'urticaire à certains imams
[Musique]
dakar 3 millions d'habitants je visite
un centre de santé avec une ong financée
par les games
depuis leur siège à 9800 km ils gèrent
leurs stocks qui nous ont fourni les
tablettes et dès que je valide et ils
savent qu à telle heure par exemple
comme on est là il est 11h30 la roseraie
[Musique]
bill et melinda sont fans des chiffres
et du reporting
ils veulent voir en direct ce qu'on fait
de leurs sous et voici l'une des
bénéficiaires de cette contraception
express fattouh a déjà cinq enfants
c'est pile la moyenne nationale mais
fatou a eu des grossesses rapprochées
elle a voulu s'arrêter là sayah la
presse a changé sa vie
[Musique]
on peut te faire la piqûre omra à la
cuisse ou sur le ventre tu choisi
l'endroit que tu préfères début 2015
fattouh a été une des pionnières pour
seulement 1 dollar l'injection elle a
l'esprit libre pour trois mois
quand on tombe souvent enceinte on
devient vite malades
pour moi ça n'allait pas maintenant j'ai
la santé et mes enfants aussi la
seringue c'est bien c'est pratique on te
fait une piqûre et ensuite tu es
tranquille
les comprimés je pourrais oublier de les
prendre
certaines femmes prennent la petite
seringue en cachette de leur mari paf à
tout le sien s'est laissé convaincre
il voyait bien que les grossesses épuisé
sa femme
[Musique]
personne ne m'a obligé
j'ai compris que c'était bien pour moi
aussi comme chef de famille on en a
parlé ça c'est fait vous comptez à voir
combien d'enfants ça dieu seul le sait
de toute façon je ne compte pas
m'arrêter une seule épouse
la contraception est elle soluble dans
l'islam le coran ne l'interdît pas mais
dans certaines mosquées
l'idée passe mal
donc lui c'est l'imam ndiaye et le plein
il fallait génial il apprécie pas trois
l'imam ndiaye m'a accordé un rendez-vous
du bout des lèvres
on peut me suivre
oui on enlève les chaussures oui il a
entendu parler de la petite seringue des
gates
mais pour lui le planning familial est
une catastrophe planétaire dans une
société il faut que le taux de fécondité
supérieur à 2% en 2007 taux de fécondité
en france et un but de cette allemagne
1,3 ils ont causé le problème vous ne
vous n'arrivez pas à renouveler à votre
jeune âge lorsqu'ils vont sur le sénégal
pour le sénégal on est entre 4 5
bon ils ont commencé à nous imposer là
où qu'elle planifie rien
maintenant on est où un nouvel quatre
dessins ses malheurs c'est très mal ça
c'est pas du conflit c'est un complot
mais ça faisait quoi mais c'est quoi le
but du complot c'est pour entraîner les
jeunes suisses sénégalaise est de faire
de ta bouche et à l'idée de ne pas se
marier
du fait de les appliquer la liberté
sexuelle
ses parents
la philanthropie en soi l'imam n'a rien
contre ces mêmes le troisième pilier de
l'islam
la zakat le don aux plus pauvres c'est
peut-être difficile à croire pour vous
mais pour ces personnes comme bill gates
melinda le planning familial seller
akata ce qui sauve de la vie de femme
attention dossier sensible occident
sexualité et islam
tout était réuni pour un échec mais les
gates se sont fondus dans le décor pas
de bureau pas de logo
pour faire bouger les esprits sans les
braquer la fondation utilise les médias
locaux
elle finance par exemple sud fm la
première radio privée du pays donc là
c'est l'émission allô docteurs qui
s'apprête à démarrer pendant une heure
et demie être question de planning
familial
[Musique]
talbi midi en continu tous des espaces
morgan naissance à +2 contre la
mortalité maternelle à la faute et vous
parlez d'espacement des naissances vous
ne parlez pas de contraception ça ça
commence par les très très attention à
ses nouveaux co billère les mots
interdits
c'est le truc de peut-être limitation
des naissances limitation des naissances
parce que quand tu dis limité pour eux
plus de limite à 2 à un enfant ou bien
apprendre enfants et ça c'est pas normal
interdit par l'islam pour l'argument des
régissent ce qu'ils nous disent même
quand je dis espaces et ça veut dire que
tu pouvais autant d'enfants espaces et
là c'est moins brutal
c'est plus facile à accepter merci
beaucoup
la voie des ondes sera t-elle plus forte
que le chant du muezzin
il y a deux ans une sénégalais sur 10
utiliser un moyen de contraception
aujourd'hui c'est une sur cinq
la fondation contribuer à révolutionner
les moeurs d'un pays entier bill et
melinda bat tous les records de
philanthropie leur fondation a distribué
plus de 36 milliards de dollars depuis
sa création en 1997 elle a sauvé plus de
10 millions de vies qui dit mieux
une philanthropie plus pro plus efficace
les gates applique les méthodes du
business à l'humanitaire et ça ça a tapé
dans l'oeil de leurs copains
milliardaires notamment du plus riche
d'entre eux en 2006 la fondation est
devenu un ménage à trois on est
enthousiaste
la fondation s'est trouvé un troisième
patron film ils avaient tous les trois
devant vous lui faites à l'époque
deuxième fortune mondiale juste derrière
bill gates ce jour là il fait un premier
chèque de 30 milliards de dollars
ce sont des gens qui vont savoir
dépenser bien mieux que moi c'est un
chèque en blanc
buffet tu donnes sans se mêler des
dépenses warren buffett
un grand père noël inattendu
il est né au lendemain du krach de 29 et
sa vie entière s'est joué à la bourse
le petit gars du nebraska s'est imposé
comme le roi de wall street warren est
réputé pour son flair et son avarice
il conduit des voitures de milieu de
gamme n'a pas changé de maison depuis
1958 et mange à tous les repas la même
chose
doger et glace à la vanille arrosez de
sa boisson fétiche le coca
ça tombe bien il en détient près de 10%
à titre personnel soit 18 milliards de
dollars au cours actuel
une vie bien réglée jusqu'à ce que sous
la fleur de bill gates
l'oncle picsou se réveille en robin des
bois
depuis voir un élu fait à la fois des
convertis il veut entraîner avec lui
d'autres amis super riches pour qu'il se
déleste d'au moins la moitié de leurs
milliards 152 ont déjà accepté c'est la
building pledge la promesse de don
à 86 ans warren fait la forme il gère
son fonds d'investissement depuis cette
bonne ville de mar il est toujours
troisième fortune mondiale est toujours
très occupé il nous a quand même accordé
l'une de ses rares interviews aux médias
français
il confirme oui ils comptent bien se
délester de tous les milliards qui lui
reste via la fondation gates
pas pour se faire mousser apparemment ça
ils s'en moquent plutôt parce que le
moment est venu
vous avez passé toutes les crevettes
construire cette fortune vous ai fait
preuve de patience d'efforts de talent
c'est pas un peu bizarre de vouloir tout
donner aujourd'hui
non je me suis amusé du début à la fin
en gagnant cet argent si vous m'aviez
dit il ya soixante ans que je gagnerais
juste un salaire de cadre pour faire
tout ce que j'ai fait j'aurais fait
quand même l'argent n'a plus d'utilité
passé un certain stade
sur les 65 milliards de dollars que je
possède 64 trois quarts ne me servent à
rien mais ils peuvent être utiles aux
autres ils peuvent acheter des vaccins
ils peuvent offrir de l'éducation ils
peuvent faire beaucoup de choses mais à
moi ça ne sert à rien les riches doivent
s'ils se sentir obligés de donner non ça
dépend des gens avec le gearing pledge
la promesse de don on a demandé à des
personnes très riches
si elle pouvait donner la moitié de leur
fortune il y en a qui ont répondu oui et
d'autres non et j'ai des très bons amis
parmi ceux qui ont dit non moi même je
n'aurais pas donné la moitié de ma
fortune à 40 ou 50 ans
j'en avais besoin je voulais qu'elle me
rapporte encore plus d'argent
on a ensuite demandé à papy dollars
laquelle de ces bonnes oeuvres l'avait
rendu le plus fier plutôt que de nous
répondre
warren nous a refilé un numéro de
téléphone
subit de son fils howard
et c'est comme ça que l'on s'est
retrouvé à des captures dans les grandes
plaines de l'héninois embarqués par la
police au milieu de nulle part
on va faire un contrôle au croisement de
la rue jacob et de la rue hélène c'est
un pick-up chevrolet
[Musique]
le shérif adjoint par vérifier
l'identité il a 62 ans il est bénévole
et n'a pas de souci d'argent
c'est le fils de warren buffett
[Musique]
merci j'ai juste quelques questions
est-ce que vous avez quelque chose
d'illégal dans votre véhicule
non monsieur pas de cocaïne d'héroïne
marijuana non monsieur
pas de grosses sommes d'argent non
j'apprécie votre coopération passé une
bonne soirée et soyez prudents merci
merci à vous il ne se passe pas grand
chose les samedis soirs parisse y est
porté l'uniforme c'est surtout une
histoire de potes je suis avec le
meilleur shérif de tous les états unis
des captures peut dormir tranquille
howard weil
[Musique]
son père ne quitte jamais le nebraska
buffett junior lui a beaucoup bourlingué
en prenant parfois son gilet pare-balles
de shérif avec lui congo sierra leone
des points chauds là où il ya la guerre
il y a souvent la fin
howard a sa propre fondation il finance
les distribution du programme
alimentaire mondial
il sillonne l'afrique
[Musique]
votre père vous appelle l'indiana jones
de la philanthropie et à voir mon père
m'appelle comme ça
à 24 ans c'est assez justifiée avec ce
que j'aime faire dans la vie j'aime
prendre beaucoup de risques j'aime aller
dans les endroits compliqué mais
pourquoi ce n'est pas qu'une question de
risque ou de challenge
c'est aussi des zones où personne ne
fait rien parce que les gens ont décrété
que c'était trop difficile ou trop
dangereux exemple dans le kivu le far
west des grands lacs howard a dépensé 20
millions de dollars pour ce barrage
le président kabila est venu en personne
l inauguration le président kabila est
venu couper le ruban en décembre mais il
ya deux ans quand on lui a dit qu'on
allait construire la centrale
il a pensé qu'on était singles et qu'on
y arriverait parle en fait on n'a pas
vraiment négocier avec le gouvernement
on a juste construit la centrale lui
c'est un bon ami koffi boas il dit au
ghana il a une ferme un petit institut
qu'on a monté ensemble c'est dans la
banlieue de kumasi au ghana
ensemble on donne des cours aux fermiers
du coin qui veulent se lancer dans des
cultures sans labour avec l'argent de
papa awards c'est aussi acheter des
terres chez lui aux états unis où il
mène en toute liberté des expériences
agronomique avant de les exporter son
ambition révolutionner l'agriculture
pour nourrir la planète
ce matin il plante du maïs 13000 760
grammes à l'hectare pas une de plus
quand j'appuie sur ce bouton c'est le
gps qui prend la main il réalise mon
tracteur comme il faut
vous aimez ça j'adore ça j'ai toujours
adoré ça
j'ai planté mon premier maïs à 4 ans
dans le jardin
mes parents me prenait pour un fou pour
moi c'est le meilleur bureau du monde
il n'y a rien de mieux au monde que
d'être assis sur un tracker howard aime
les gros joujou et malgré les apparences
c'est un écolo son truc c'est la culture
sans labour
là par exemple son méga tracteur a
enfoncé les graines sans retourner la
terre on voit aussi les tiges desséché
de la dernière récolte des résidus qui
protège le sol et lui servent de
couverture et voilà ce que ça donne
quand les graines ont poussé super là
bas regarde comme cette humide on a créé
des conditions favorables pour les
insectes et pour les verts ça permet
d'augmenter la fertilité du sol font des
trous et l'eau rentre mieux dans la
terre que ce sont nos amis ces vers sont
nos amis
[Musique]
nourrir les sols et les protéger c'est
le credo d'howard fait ce paysan ou
poches profondes et il exporte ses idées
très loin du michigan au ghana il
investit des millions là bas en afrique
de l'ouest pour que les ghanéens mangent
à leur faim sans sacrifier l'avenir ni
abîmer leur propre sol donatien le
spécialiste environnement de la team
papillons s'est envolé vers l'ouest du
pays où howard buffett a installé sa
ferme pilote
voici la ferme de buffett junior vue du
ciel la région a l'air fertile pourtant
ces soldes rouges sont abîmés par
l'homme c'est le fermier en chef koffi
boas qui me reçoit un ami d'howard fait
ça ces awards
ça c'est moi qu'au fil et l'huile c'est
le président du ghana
une belle histoire commencée par hasard
un jour awards le milliardaire traverse
la région
incognito il s'est présenté comme
fermier il était vraiment passionné par
la culture sans labour
il a rencontré des paysans et quand ils
allaient remonter en voiture et repartir
il m'a dit qu'il était le fils de warren
buffett
je savais qu'il était un warren buffett
et là je me suis dit mon dieu j'ai
rencontré le fils d'un milliardaire
depuis le centre n'arrête pas de grandir
et tout ce qu'il veut avec et ont grandi
car aux arts nous a entendus on s'envole
[Musique]
la ferme est à la fois un laboratoire et
une école avec un combat prioritaire
convaincre les paysans d'arrêter ça la
culture traditionnelle sur brûlis la
première année ça fait une meilleure
récolte mais ensuite ça se gâte les
arbres brûlés du coup il n'y a plus de
racines pour retenir les sols c'est la
couche de surface qui s'en va
et c'est celle qui contient tous les
nutriments ça ne dit rien de bon comment
sera la récolte cette année très
mauvaise très mauvaise la terre de
surface la meilleure s'en va peu à peu
et c'est la pluie qui l'emmène vous
voyez l'eau colorée qui s'en va la pluie
est en train de lessiver le sol au ghana
et surtout dans cette région en juin et
en juillet il pleut tous les jours dans
le dialecte jeudi si on a un mot at on
tout ça veut dire 9 mai par jour terre
lessivé paysans appauvris
ici chacun vit avec moins d'un euro par
jour
arrêtez les brûlis et changer les
mentalités c'est le rêve de ward fait et
c'est le quotidien de son ami koffi il
enchaîne les formations mieux qu'un long
discours
un coup d'oeil aux parcelles le secret
le voici un couvert végétal
c'est lui qui va retenir la terre la
protéger à la fois de la pluie et du
soleil
c'est déçoit regardez il n'y a pas de
mauvaises herbes rien comme ça recouvre
le sol vous n'avez pas de mauvaises
herbes
ce couvert va nourrir votre sol et il va
le protéger de l'érosion
ici on nous allons planter
nous allons juste éclaircir ce couvert
végétal le coupés à la machette même
couper les tiges sont encore un manteau
efficace
c'est le moment de planter le maïs ou
les haricots le sol est humide à
regarder
il ya de l'eau dedans la chaleur du
soleil ne va pas chauffer le sol
directement donc vous gardez votre eau
avec une terre riche et une image donc
là je rentre sur une parcelle qui a été
brûlé donc le maïs fait à peu près ma
taille et il est chétif et au fond une
parcelle on a mis un couvert végétal et
là les maïs sont carrément deux fois
plus grand que moi donc ça fait quand
même une sacrée différence avec les
mêmes grain lépi de gauche est bien plus
gros en trois ans six mille personnes
ont suivi la formation
[Musique]
il en a coûté 3 millions d'euros à
howard buffett
[Musique]
mais dans son fief de l'illinois le fils
à papa milliardaire reste modeste nous
les occidentaux ce qu'on soit américains
britanniques ou français on a souvent
tout faux on va sur place pour expliquer
aux gens ce qu'il faut faire et on ne
comprend pas les circonstances la
culture locale où les conséquences
imprévues de nos décisions nous sommes
trop arrogant est ce vrai que votre père
vous a donné un milliard en 2006 en vous
mettant au défi de changer le monde et
il m'a redonné un autre milliard deux
ans plus tard depuis ça ne s'arrête pas
il me redonne un tous les deux ans mais
ça va à la fondation ce n'est pas pour
moi
howard est un philanthrope heureux c'est
lui donne la grosse banane de claquer
l'argent de papa
pour ceux qui en ont le plus besoin
[Musique]
dans la dernière lettre à baud
actionnaire vous êtes optimiste
pensez vous vraiment que le monde va
mieux bien sûr que le monde va mieux
si vous aviez le choix entre vivre dans
le monde de 2016 ou dans celui de 1816
imaginez juste que vous avez mal aux
dents le dentiste vous attache vous dit
non ça va en fait et lui il vous
désinfecte au whisky on vit tellement
mieux aujourd'hui c'est le mans qui n'a
mieux ou seulement l'occident il faut
que tout le monde aille mieux il y à
sept milliards d'habitants sur terre et
tout n'est qu'une question de chance
j'ai eu la chance de naître américain
avec un bon câblage du cerveau qui était
valorisé dans le système capitaliste
comme dit mon ami bill gates si j'étais
né il ya quelques milliers d'années
j'aurai fini dans l'estomac d'un
prédateur c'est pas courir tu ne sais
pas grimper aux arbres et tu sers de
repas un animal voulez vous laissez
derrière vous je ne m'occupe pas trop de
ma postérité je voudrais plutôt qu'on
inscrive sur ma tombe
ici reposent l'homme qui eut la vie la
plus longue de l'histoire
[Musique]
en tout cas de warren edwards buffett
l'histoire retiendra c'est sur le fil en
trope d'ailleurs aux états unis c'est
une tradition avec deux grands ancêtres
deux figures marquantes qui ont laissé
des traces
david rockefeller d'abord leurs rois du
pétrole
c'est l'homme le plus riche de tous les
temps avec l'équivalent de 3 à 400
milliards de dollars d'aujourd'hui très
pieux il fonde l'université de chicago
et finance la recherche médicale
son rival au tournant du siècle
s'appelle wang le carnegie
il est presque aussi riche c'est le roi
de l'acier un patron redouté qui va
couvrir le pays des bibliothèques
publiques
sa phrase préférée tout homme qui meurt
riches demeures déshonoré aujourd'hui la
générosité s'est mondialisée et les
fondations philanthropiques se sont
multipliés la moitié d'entre elles
n'existaient pas il ya 20 ans elles sont
un royaume
le pays des banques et de la croix rouge
la suisse 13000 fondation pour huit
millions d'habitants
record mondial le secteur s'est
professionnalisé c'est devenu une
industrie à part entière qui embauchent
il y a même des formations à
l'université comme ici à bâle
aujourd'hui dispenser des largesses ne
suffit plus
l'argent doit être bien gérée et le
service après vente irréprochable donné
ça s'apprend guerre de foehn chorbane
dirige le centre européen des études
fine entre aupic la philanthropie vous
le disais a explosé ces dernières années
qu'est ce que ça dit de nous de notre
civilisation
toutes ces fondations ça prouve déjà
qu'il y a beaucoup de richesses mais
c'est aussi le signe de l'
individualisme les philanthropes ne
pense pas collectif il ne crée pas des
associations ils s'offrent une fondation
et paie des gens pour faire le travail
c'est une façon pour eux d'exprimer leur
valeur et puis d'un autre côté c'est
aussi le signe d'une insécurité avec le
futur dans les gens ne croient plus que
les états peuvent résoudre les problèmes
sociaux de notre époque se passer de
l'état appliqué les méthodes du business
dans les domaines les plus inattendus
apparaît aussi ça existe j'ai rendez
vous avec un geek de 49 ans ce qui veut
révolutionner les méthodes
d'enseignement
xavier niel pour l'éducation il a tout
un programme
le fondateur de free qui a secoué le
marché de téléphonie en france se lance
dans l'éducation avec la même énergie
son école s'appelle 42 le principe des
études gratuites pour les élèves
sélectionnés
c'est xavier niel qui paie et ça lui
coûte 6 millions d'euros par an vous
avez un plateau aux cee
c'est l'école ces trois plateaux comme
ça tous ces jeunes qui sont ici ils ont
fouillé avant de sélection on a entre 50
et 100 mille jeunes qui chaque année
s'inscrire en ligne font un petit test
en ligne c'est un test biologique on va
prendre les 3000 meilleur et on va leur
demander de venir dans l'école et de
travailler pendant un mois et on l'a on
va tester leur motivation a réussi à
s'en sortir et vous tester à la fois
leur capacité à résister à la formation
et leurs maîtresses et leurs prêts
motivation leur envie de réussir un mois
de test à coder nuitées jour une
sélection quasi militaire seuls 2 800
arriveront jusqu'au bout dans le monde
selon jan il faut s'accrocher
[Musique]
passé la porte de l'école surprise
ici pas de profs seulement des tutos
[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue pour cette première
vidéo du jour 0,2 comme dans un jeu
vidéo
on progresse par paliers et en forme des
équipes pour s'entraîner
vivo est qualifié pour le corps et on a
fait tous les deux la même chose hier et
l'uimm corrige aujourd'hui moi je vais
encore et j'ai d'autres aujourd'hui
d'accord qu'on a appris en même temps et
on va potentiellement apprendre de nos
erreurs en même temps ce qu'orange leur
truc c'est sérieux une école son prof je
trouve c'est bien ça l'est parce que
pour le coup c'est juste nous qui sommes
indépendants et c'est à nous de gérer
tout de a à z
on n'a pas trop d'eau à l'erreur pour
réussir il faut une auto discipline de
fer
et devinez comment ces jeunes geeks se
change en cité
bien vite un siège étant donné qu on n'a
pas d'horaires fixes qu'on n'a pas ce
professeur on n'a pas d'obligation
donc il faut pas abuser non pourquoi
vous l'école ne ferme jamais 365 jours
par an 24 heures sur 24
certains vont jusqu'à dormir sur place
[Musique]
et l'on doit quelques hommes en fait tu
peux de temps que tu ramènes pas ton
buzz qui s'affairent à laquelle lui la
justice valide tout cela et tous les
soirs de prendre sa douche et il est
prêt comme à la maison
les serviettes sache dans l'escalier on
trouve de tout la garante de la formule
attire des étudiants des actifs des
chômeurs près de la moitié n'a pas le
bac
xavier niel a voulu une école pour ceux
qui n'aiment pas l'école
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que vous inspire avec l'envié
n'y est pas et nous paye nos études donc
si tu pourras génial avec les autres
écoles d'informatique privé s'est
facilement jusqu'à 7000 euros l'année
qui passent leur médecin est-ce que vous
allez que c'est lui il vous donne une
seconde chance
ben ça va dépendre des personnes par
exemple moi j'ai le bal j'aurais pu
faire une scolarité classique
oui sauf que je trouve ça complètement
pourri en fait le système scolaire en
france et justement cette école est
vraiment adapté pour des gens comme moi
aussi des jambes un combat lbp à phuket
est vrai truc qui leur plaisait pas être
revenir dans l'informatique ils arrivent
ici ils ont appris l'équivalent d'un bts
informatique en un mois dont qu'ils ont
une envie de réussir une soif
d'apprendre une semaine d'avancé soit de
progresser ils ont peur de rien et c'est
eux qui changeront ni elle finance il
peut se le permettre
c'est la dixième fortunes de france avec
8 milliards d'euros mais il reste un cas
isolé dans ce classement où l'on compte
peu de philanthropes
vous êtes un humain l'entropie
représente 2% du pib en france dix fois
mois est ce qu'on est est-ce qu'on a des
oursins dans les poches
qu'est-ce qu'on a nous les français pour
le pays plus anciens de le culture de
passer on fait moins attention à l'autre
et les états unis que vous citiez est un
pays plus je dois fait plus moderne dans
lequel l'inspection sociale a fonctionné
on se souvient peut-être plus d'où on
vient et où on va mais pense que vous
êtes dans un monde dans lequel avoir
trop d'argent et que vous avez des gens
toujours plus riche au monde
à un moment ça posera un problème donc
au delà du beau geste que vous pouvez
faire vous avez quand même besoin d'une
manière ou d'une autre de partager ne
croyez vous pas que c'est à l'état comme
normalement de redistribuer wii devrait
distribuer et de s'occuper de l'intérêt
général mais personne n'y croit personne
n'y croit et si vous voulez est ce qu'on
est capable de créer l'école où on est
ici d'une manière publique
moi je sais pas faire ça parce que parce
que déjà ça n'aurait pas la même image
légende et je n'aurais pas le même envie
d'y aller et ça ne marche pas parce
qu'on est dans un monde complètement
atypique où on va vous dire les pendant
un mois on le fait de ses 450 heures et
au rythme du temps de travail cct
remonter quelques uns pour moi ça marche
pas ce qu'est ce que vous racontez
et si vous voulez on est obligé de
casser des barrières si on veut créer
quelque chose de quasi seule la société
civile est capable de faire ça et c'est
une vraie chance et de la technologie
parce que si nous parlons de grands
parents voulaient de créer leur activité
pour réussir il avait besoin
d'énormément de capitaux aujourd'hui de
chez vous avec très peu d'argent donc
vous venez vous pouvez créer google vous
pouvez créer cet achat d'une peau et
créer ça sans moyens et ces gens là dans
les noms des gens qui sont riches en
nouvelles technologies sont arrivés de
d'un milieu social normal et et ont
réussi et je ne le font pas publiquement
où ça ne se voit pas mais tous sont dans
des choses ont des agglos philanthropie
fort avons autant de la vieille économie
en devenait philanthrope sur le tard
pour terminer en beauté sa carrière de
super riches
les nouveaux milliardaires s'y mettent
de plus en plus jeunes sitôt fortune
faite
xavier niel n'a pas attendu la
cinquantaine
pour mark zuckerberg ce fut encore plus
rapide 31 ans à la naissance de sa fille
il annonce qu'il lègue 99 % de ses
actions facebook 45 milliards de dollars
la cause qu'il s'est choisi l'enfance
[Musique]
au kenya zuckerberg a également investi
10 millions de dollars dans une start up
américaine dédiée à l'éducation
le
[Musique]
pour voir ce que cela donne sur le
terrain
hugo van ophem reporter papillon s'est
rendu dans le plus grand bidonville
d'afrique kibera au sud de nairobi la
capitale
un million d'habitants un sur trois ne
sait ni lire ni écrire
[Musique]
le voici dans l'une des rares écoles du
bidonville dans les classes pas
d'électricité et des élèves en haillons
pas simple de faire court les
instituteurs sont mal payés et mal
équipés c'est tellement décourageant
parfois ça donne même envie de renoncer
comment est ce que vous pouvez atteindre
les objectifs avec un élève qui n'a même
pas d'électricité chez lui et et
regarder les livres on en a un seul pour
10 enfants
donc ce qu'on fait c'est qu on recopie
les pages au tableau pour que chaque
enfant puisse y avoir accès la
directrice a créé l'école avec les
moyens du bord
[Musique]
ici c'est censé être la bibliothèque
mais vous n'avez pas de livres je n'ai
pas de chaise non plus j'ai juste
quelques livres dans ce carton même dans
les classes je n'ai pas toujours deux
chaises donc j'essaie de demander aux
parents d'aider un peu mais souvent ils
n'ont rien il n'y avait pas de livres et
vous cuisinez ici oui donc vous cuisiner
dans votre bureau
oui j'ai cuisine dans mon bureau c'est
quoi du riz et des patates
comme ça les élèves mangeront au moins à
midi
comment le kenya va t'il éduquer ses
enfants 40% de la population a moins de
13 ans c'est là qu'intervient la
start-up financé par mark zuckerberg
[Musique]
voilà c'est là donc on dirait pas comme
ça mais on entre à bridge académie qui
est une école unique au monde à première
vue rien de particulier dans les classes
on entend les mouches voler pourtant les
profs sont des petits nouveaux
[Musique]
l'an dernier
laura était encore coiffeuse nina elle
était ouvrière agricole et marlon
chauffeur de bus
aucun d'entre nous et aller à la fac ma
passion ça a toujours été d'enseigner
mais je n'ai pas eu les moyens d'aller à
l'université et d'avoir mon diplôme je
m'étais résigné et j'avais choisi un job
par hasard aujourd'hui c'est mon rêve
qui se réalise je suis très content et
c'est la tablette qui m'a permis d'être
prof je lis la leçon c'est très efficace
et oui le vrai prof c'est cette petite
tablette c'est elle qui déroule la leçon
de a à z
bon on va commencer la leçon vous n'êtes
pas vraiment des profs plutôt des
répétiteurs même si les cours eux sont
rédigés par des spécialistes sans
diplôme ces nouveaux enseignants ont des
petits salaires et la scolarité coûte
donc moins cher 6 dollars par mois
c'est dix fois moins qu'une bonne école
privée au kenya
misy ça ne coûte pas cher donc même les
enfants pas trop riches comme moi on
peut aller à l'école
au kenya un million d'enfants ne vont
pas à l'école
un marché énorme pour bridge qui
scolarise déjà cent vingt mille élèves à
travers le pays
[Musique]
il est 6 heures du matin à gangemi un
autre bidonville de nairobi
[Musique]
july 9 ans se prépare pour l'école elle
est à bridge academy elle est allée à
l'école publique du quartier elle avait
toujours les mêmes notes
elle finissait toujours onzième de sa
classe c'était toujours pareil every
time
et puis je me suis rendu compte que les
enfants dont les parents étaient plus
riches étaient toujours classé premier
c'étaient les chouchous abri il ya une
compétition équitable entre les élèves
des fois ma fille et 9e des fois 4e ou
même première compétition
c'est pas une question d'argent non ce
n'est plus une question d'argent mais de
niveau
en route vers l'une des 400 écoles
bridge du kenya
[Musique]
voici l'équipe autour du directeur il va
expédier sa réunion pédagogique en cinq
minutes
bonjour tout le monde
bon va synchroniser la leçon du jour
vous avez vos tablettes directeur ou
plutôt manager gipson à 24 ans d'abord
les professeurs enregistrent leur de
leur arrivée sur la tablette et ensuite
je leur envoie à chacun le programme du
jour
d'où vient le contenu des cours
d'aujourd'hui d'internet
non ça vient de notre quartier général
anaérobie les leçons sont rédigées puis
mis sur un serveur est envoyé sur mon
smartphone c'est bon pour toi ok bonne
journée un bridge academy on ne badine
pas avec la discipline
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chaque matin le directeur motive les
trous on a des examens cette semaine
donc je veux que tout le monde révise
les beaucoup d'accords qui va réussir
l'examen
attention ceux qui n'ont pas levé la
main vaut le rater
allez en la tablette commence le cours
ce matin c'est grammaire pas le temps
pour des questions
tout est minuté script et même les
félicitations aux élèves sont rédigées à
l'avant ce qu'elle va dire
pour la relation maître élève peut mieux
faire
elles se résument souvent un simple clic
en revanche avec ses tablettes même au
fin fond du kenya les enfants peuvent
suivre des cours de bonne qualité à un
tarif défiant toute concurrence sur mon
smartphone je contrôle tout même la
ponctualité des professeurs vous
moderniser la façon d'enseigner c'est ça
je vous montre j'ai des onglets pour
noter les professeurs ont les notes deux
fois par semaine par exemple si ce
professeur c'est mal habillé ce matin je
fais du mètre 1 2 ou 1 3 sur 10 donc
vous êtes vraiment un manager comme un
mcdonald's puis comme mcdonald's
tout est informatisé chez nous et c'est
comme ça dans les 400 école de bridge
académie des méthodes qui ferait
grimacer en europe
[Musique]
pourtant les premiers résultats sont là
neuf ans après le lancement
les meilleurs éléments ou obtenu des
bourses comme jackson
ces notes lui ont valu une place dans ce
lycée privé l'un des meilleurs du pays
aujourd'hui il porte un blazer al
anglaise et il voit loin et plaisent ici
tout est vert ou disent pas d'où je
viens tout est gris sont entrés depuis
que je suis là j'ai changé d'objectif
dans la vie avant je voulais devenir
ingénieur aéronautique
mais maintenant je veux faire de la
politique il ya trop de corruption au
kenya
moi je voudrais changer les choses
disons en devenant président par exemple
j'y travaille
président ou pas bridge a déjà changé la
vie de jackson
et l'école 2.0 gagne même de l'argent
le bénéfice est top secret et le chiffre
d'affaires annuel frise les 10 millions
de dollars mark zuckerberg a eu du flair
et comme bill gates
il fait de la charité une affaire de
famille j'espère que ma fille mais pas
seulement elle toute la nouvelle
génération auront une meilleure vie de
la noc
chacun d'entre nous doit se mobiliser
pour avoir de l'impact pour changer les
choses dans le night une charité bien
ordonnée et surtout savamment orchestré
le nouveau riche écrit lui-même sa
propre légende
parce que donner aux autres c'est que du
bonheur et en plus c'est bon pour
l'image
[Musique]
voilà donc à quoi ressemblera notre
futur une générosité privée qui se met
en scène avec des milliards d'eur
devenus des gourous prenez par exemple
l'inventeur de cette petite fiole
aux états unis il s'en vend plus de 1000
par seconde angie une potion magique qui
dure cinq heures les chauffeurs routiers
adore ça
d'ailleurs il faut prendre la route pour
rencontrer le richissime concepteurs de
cette boisson énergisante
il vit dans une lointaine banlieue de
détroit ménages bagarre va a déjà eu
plusieurs vies il a étudié les maths à
princeton s'est retiré dans un ashram en
inde avant de commercialiser sa fiole
vitaminé et de rendre ses concurrents ça
c'est tous mes concurrents
quand on s'est lancé dans le business
des boissons énergisantes
tout le monde a voulu faire pareil il y
en a eu plus de 350 coca cola pepsi ils
ont tous vu le nouveau marché et sont
arrivés en cours et vous les a vite fait
je ne dirais pas qu'on les a tuées
disons qu'ils ne sont plus là
[Musique]
maintenant je dois être le seul
milliardaire à travailler en open space
on se croirait dans une pme et pourtant
il pèse 4 milliards de dollars
c'est ce qu'on appelle un méga riches
je ne sais pas ce que ça veut dire
à partir d'un certain point on s'en
fiche de l'argent je conduis moi même ma
voiture je n'ai pas du tout je vis de la
même façon que quand je posais mettons 1
% de ce que je suis aujourd'hui les gens
comme moi qui ont créé leur entreprise
ce qu'on aime nous c'est travailler
wilrijk rock c'est ça qui nous amuse
plus que tout le reste
manoj a de l'énergie à revendre alors il
a monté une autre boîte pour se
consacrer à sa vraie passion
bricoler des inventions pour
révolutionner le quotidien des pays
pauvres
[Musique]
son dernier brevet unique et miniatures
de production d'eau douce ça c'est une
machine qui transforme l'eau de mer en
eau potable
normalement les usines de
dessalinisation sont gigantesques
il faut cinq ou six ans pour les
construire
le problème c'est que les besoins en eau
potable sont si énormes dans le monde
que si à chaque fois on met cinq ou six
ans pour construire la moitié des gens
seront morts là c'est une toute petite
machine
il faut qu'elles soient hyper simples
pourraient être produites en masse comme
un lave vaisselle
[Musique]
son truc à man of low tech des
bricolages tout simple pas très
spectaculaire mais hyper utile heures
[Musique]
je vais pédaler et regarder ce qui va se
passer
toute l'électricité que ça va produire
tout ça vient juste de ce vélo pendant
que je [ __ ] l'idée c'est de pédaler
pendant une heure pour avoir de
l'électricité pour 24 heures soit vous
créer de l'électricité en direct pendant
que vous pédalez soit vous charger les
batteries en pédalant pendant une heure
et cette batterie vous pouvez l'utiliser
toute la journée
en général les philanthropes aime
montrer qu'il donne c'est très arrogant
il faut traiter les gens comme des
clients ils sont au dessus
vous êtes en dessous il ne faut pas leur
donner ce qu'on a envie de leur donner
mais répondre à leurs besoins c'est pour
ça que je les considère comme des
clients et même si on finance tout
qu'est ce que ça change ma note je
n'aime pas trop la ramener sur ses
actions de bienfaisance la philanthropie
bling bling ou l'eau claironne sa
générosité devant la bonne société
ce n'est pas son encre
ce serait quoi d'être définition de la
philanthropie
ma définition c'est être au service de
la moitié malchanceuse de l'humanité
pour certains c'est au contraire donner
des millions de dollars 1 musique ou
aider des universités déjà riche et
leurs finances et de nouveaux bâtiments
moi ça me fait rigoler pour moi ce n'est
pas de la philanthropie
qu'est ce que vous allez laisser la
postérité ça c'est un truc de riches les
riches veulent toujours qu'on se
souvienne d'eux pour quelque chose que
leur nom reste attaché à une cause
moi je ne comprends pas cette notion
pour moi je serais mort qu'est ce que ça
me fera qu'on se souvienne de moi ou pas
votre fils donc n'aura pas votre fortune
non il n'aura pas d'argent mon job ce
n'est pas de bousiller sa vie en lui
donnant un milliard de dollars c'est mon
point de vue
presque personne n'est d'accord avec moi
là dessus
de toute façon presque personne n'est
d'accord avec moi sur rien ces milliards
manoche allait donner aux autres à ceux
qui en ont vraiment besoin
en commençant par le pays de ses parents
l'inde l'un d'eux justement le pays des
intouchables et des milliardaires il y
en a une centaine c'est plus qu'en
russie ou au royaume uni le sud rattrape
son retard et se met lui aussi la
philanthropie avec cette idée
renversante et des lots nord qui parfois
en a bien besoin
c'est la silicon valley indienne
bangalore et c'est ici qu'ils exercent
notre prochain philanthrope une légende
vivante des vies chez ti est un
cardiologue richissime mais il est aussi
l'ancien médecin de mère teresa son
utopie elle me rendre accessible à tous
une médecine de qualité et pour
démocratiser les soins il a inventé le
travail à la chaîne à l'hôpital avant
d'entrer au bloc
il passe par son bureau des dizaines de
familles sont là parfois depuis la
veille départ on va faire une petite
incision dans la poitrine et ensuite une
autre de 4 mm dans le coeur et après on
recourt la consultation est terminée
cinq minutes top chrono
on touche le pied du docteur en signe de
respect ça va bien se passer
ici des biches et i c le boss il est
multimillionnaire mais continue à manier
le bistouri
quelle température 18 augmente le flux
et surveille bien l'artère coronaire
[Musique]
l'hôpital est le plus grand centre
cardiologique au monde
l'anesthésiste suit plusieurs opérations
en même temps
[Musique]
ici on essaie de faire le maximum
d'opérations à battre c'est l'idée du
docteur chétive au maximum de croyants
de malades pourrait bien vous occupez à
la fois là je m'occupe de deux patients
mais le maximum que j'ai fait ces quatre
patients ce n'est pas dangereux pour les
patients si je sens que j'en suis
capable
tout ira bien sinon j'appelle du renfort
en tout on est huit anesthésistes et
pardon le personnel fait des concessions
salariales et travail à la chaîne le
docteur shetty avoue s'être inspiré de
l'automobile et d'henry ford résultats
des prix cassés et une demande qui
explose au tableau du jour 29 opérations
dont 11 ultra délicate sur des bébés
[Musique]
le coeur du bébé fait la taille de mon
pouce vous imaginez comme ses petits ici
on opère aussi bien qu'en occident mais
ça coûte beaucoup beaucoup moins cher
qu'aux états unis
là bas une opération de ce type coûte
entre 60000 et 100 mille dollars
nous on peut le faire pour 2000 dollars
maximum
on ne refuse jamais d'opérer un enfant
s'il a besoin d'une opération
on s'en occupe qu'ils aient de l'argent
ou pas
[Musique]
il n'y a pas de sécurité sociale en inde
mais le dr shetty hélas ce petit garçon
a une malformation prix de l'opération
deux cent quarante mille roupies
c'est-à-dire 3200 euros
qu'est ce qu'on vous a dit pour l'argent
eh bien on nous a dit qu'on nous
aiderait l'opération alors ça fait deux
cent quarante mille vous pouvez payer
combien 40 40 milles
c'est tout avec 40000 il vous reste
encore 200 milles
vous les avez pas un toulonnais pourquoi
vous pleurez nom ne pleurez pas si vous
ne les avez pas on va vous aider hockey
chacun suivant ses revenus l'hôpital
règle la différence et se remboursera
avec les passions les plus riches sur
cette idée des vies shetty a construit
un empire 23 hôpitaux 1500 médecins et
un groupe valorisé 1 milliards de
dollars en bourse
le disciple de mère teresa a tout
compris aux affaires sans renier ses
valeurs
[Musique]
êtes vous un philanthrope
non je ne crois pas car ce que la
charité
ça ne peut pas être généralisable à
grande échelle alors que le business si
la vraie philanthropie c'est plutôt
d'offrir aux gens des services à des
prix abordables
non là gratuitement parce que sinon vous
n'aurez pas assez d'argent pour en faire
profiter tout le monde
je suis sûr qu'on va prouver un jour au
monde entier que tous les citoyens des
pays pauvres ou de revenus moyens
peuvent avoir accès à des soins de
grande qualité dans la dignité et
d'égalité
c'est une belle histoire indienne avec
un bouche à oreille dans toute l'asie
philippe un iranien chinois ils font le
pèlerinage de bengalore davy shetty lui
voit plus loin
il regarde vers l'occident il vient
chercher chez nous sa nouvelle clientèle
et soigne sur place
le philanthrope indien s'intéressent
même aux patients du pays le plus riche
du monde
les états unis où se soigner est devenu
un luxe comme le dr indien est il résolu
le problème
nathalie cros de l'équipe papillon a
trouvé la réponse de l'autre côté de
l'atlantique
[Musique]
miami floride j'ai rendez vous avec une
femme qui résume à elle seule le
paradoxe américain assez riche pour
s'offrir un appartement avec vue mais
trop pauvres pour payer des dépenses de
santés imprévues et c'est des vies chez
ti qui va lui sauver la mise
[Musique]
j'ai bonjour bienvenue nathalie comment
ça va bien
c'est une chouette qualité de vie que
vous avez ici il y a plein d'activités
de plein air mais là je ne peux pas en
profiter
mais attendez de voir quand j'aurai ma
nouvelle hanche
jane a eu un accident de travail elle
doit absolument se faire poser une
prothèse de hanche à miami cela
coûterait plus de cent mille dollars
hors budget pour cette décoratrice le
docteur shetty est l'inventeur de la
chirurgie à prix cassé lui propose une
formule dix fois moins cher
elle sera opérée dans les caraïbes à
1h30 de vol de miami
je prends des vêtements légers car il va
faire chaud là bas
sympa la valise pour allah l'hôpital
laissez passer pour la plage et non
comment vincent tu es maintenant c'est
dingue je suis enthousiaste alors que je
vais me faire opérer
john wayne kanye est ce que vous ne
pouvez plus faire à cause de votre
revanche
le simple fait de marcher de me pencher
de soulever des choses et justement si
quelque chose tombe par terre c'est dur
comment vous crespian de ramasser comme
ça vous devez tendre la jambe en fait
parfois je le laisse par terre
un tabac
c'est le docteur des biches et sinon il
a un beau visage
je pense qu'il y a très peu de gens
comme lui sur terre et son message a
besoin d'être diffusée jane atterri à
georgetown la capitale des îles caïmans
pour elle ses traitements vieilli
pital flambant neuf construit par le
docteur shetty permettez moi de vous
accompagner
merci infiniment à l'entrée une
concierge comme dans les grands hôtels
on va d'abord vous enregistrer comme
patiente et ensuite on commencera les
tests pré opératoire d'accord parfait ça
va aller en une seule matinée
jane enchaîne tous les tests sans passer
par la salle d'attenté
[Musique]
dans les couloirs on se croirait à
bangalore le directeur est indien comme
120 des 185 salariés
c'est votre équipe oui voici
l'infirmière en chef
nous avons besoin de personnel de haut
niveau pour les soins cardiaques et les
soins oncologiques
ce sont des compétences assez rare ici
dans les caraïbes donc nous les faisons
venir d'un pour ces indiens les îles
caïmans ont déroulé le tapis rouge
pas d'impôts pas de droits de douane sur
le matériel importé et des visas de
travail accordés les yeux fermés jane a
déjà ses résultats elle rencontre celui
qui va l'opérer
bonjour je suis le docteur alvin
on s'est parlé sur skype il ya quelques
temps
docteur alvin chirurgie orthopédique dix
ans de carrière et surtout quatre mille
opérations au compteur mes professeurs
m'ont toujours appris qu'il fallait
d'abord examiné le patient et ensuite
seulement regarder les radios avec le
tourisme médical celle inverse je vois
d'abord les radios et ensuite le patient
d'où l'importance de notre conversation
sur internet ça ne va pas être trop
compliqué non ne vous inquiétez pas je
serai une bonne patiente je vous le
promets
pour jane c j -1
[Musique]
pendant ce temps son chirurgien se
change les idées avec ses collègues
indiens
il s'est mis au sport numéro un sous ces
latitudes
[Musique]
j'espère qu'ils sont meilleurs en
chirurgie quand baseball mais l'hôpital
n'est jamais loin à l'eau remettez lui
de l'antidouleur merci 8 heures du matin
jane part au bloc
le docteur alvin manie le bistouri en
musique pop indienne à cause
trois heures plus tard c'est terminé une
petite prothèse pour jane une belle
opération pour l'humanité je pense qu'on
a prouvé que les médecins indiens sont
aussi bons que les meilleurs au monde et
pour la première fois c'est le sud qui
est le nord pas vrai avec cet hôpital
offshore
le philanthrope et au sud et les
nécessiteux au nord un renversement
complet